diana the dog receives five dog biscuits
for fetching each frisbee and three dog
biscuits for fetching each ball that
sounds like a pretty good deal
she plans to receive at most d dog
biscuits before chasing her tail that
sounds reasonable the inequality graph
below represents the set of all
combinations where diana fetches f
frisbees and fetches b balls in order to
receive at most at most d dog biscuits
because at that point she reasonably
starts chasing her tail according to the
graph and we're going to take a look at
the graph in a second according to the
graph what is the most number of dog
biscuits diana wants to receive before
chasing her tail in other words what is
d
so let's look at let's interpret this
graph properly so if we look at the
horizontal axis right over here that's f
that's the number of frisbees
number of frisbees she catches
frisbees
and this vertical axis this is the
number of balls number
of
number of balls that she gets
and we know what the total number of
biscuits is are going to be the total
from catching frisbees if she catches f
frisbees she gets five biscuits per
frisbee so the total from catching
frisbees is five f
and if she catches if she catches b
balls or retrieves b balls
so if she gets those b balls
and she gets what was it three three
biscuits per ball yep three dog biscuits
for fetching each ball the total number
of dog biscuits she gets from fetching
b balls is
three b
and so the total number of biscuits she
fetches is 5f
plus 3b this is the number of biscuits
from frisbees this is the number of
biscuits from balls
and we could see all of the allowable
combinations of number of frisbees and
number of balls here and so for example
if she catches that point right over
there eight or retrieves eight balls and
catches well that would be half of a
frisbee so that doesn't that doesn't
seem to make sense but if she if she
retrieves eight balls and and catches
one frisbee well then then that's still
okay she still hasn't met her her
maximum number of biscuits yet so how do
we think about the maximum number
biscuits well the mask maximum number of
biscuits are any of these points when
she that are sitting on this line and
notice the solutions that or all of the
points that satisfy this inequality are
all below this line so she's hitting a
maximum when she's on the line and an
easy one might be this point right over
here where we see that
where we see that frisbees zero frisbees
and 10 and 10 balls pretty much
maximizes her number of biscuits so if
she catches 10 balls so let me write
this down so if b is equal to 10
b is equal to 10 let me write this f is
0
if f
is equal to 0 and b is equal to 10 well
how many is she going to catch
how or how many biscuits is she going to
get well she's going to get this is
going to be 0 and then 3 times 10 is 30.
that's going to be 30 biscuits
30
biscuits so this point right over here
this corresponds with 30 biscuits
30
biscuits
biscuits and you could see that any of
these points along this blue line
actually correspond to 30 biscuits if
you go over here
where f is 6 let me write it here if f
is equal to 6 and b is equal to zero so
spends all of her time she she earns her
biscuits purely through frisbee catching
so this is a situation where f is equal
to six and b is equal to zero you still
have the same scenario you still have if
f is six five times six is thirty plus
three times zero well that's just going
to be once again thirty biscuits
thirty biscuits so her maximum or the
number of biscuits she needs before she
starts chasing her tail is thirty so d
is going to be 30. and in fact you can
express this inequality as saying 5f
plus 3b has to be less than or equal to
30. all right then they ask us another
question can diana fulfill her plan by
fetching can can diana fulfill her plan
by fetching four frisbees and two balls
so let's see four frisbees and two balls
this is
right over here four frisbees and two
balls
so it's not we're not saying that she
has to maximize that she has to get to
30 biscuits she just cannot not eat any
more than 30 biscuits so it seems it
seems like she can fulfill her plan let
me see the inequality graph below
represents all the combinations where
diana fetches f frisbees and b balls in
order to receive at most d dog biscuits
so let's see is is is she fulfilling her
plan by fetching
well yeah i would say
yes